accueil chaleureux pour agnès pannier
une hache-- et c'est parti pour une
visite au pas de course de lusine ps
l'occasion de rencontrer quelques jeunes
embauchés
un petit tour par la nouvelles presses
d'emboutissage et la secrétaire d'état
fait son arrivée au french fab ce
village itinérant de 3000 m² dédiés à
l'industrie d'aujourd'hui et de demain
les emplois dans l'industrie c'est des
emplois qui paye 20 % de plus en moyenne
que dans les autres secteurs c'est des
emplois qui sont durables
c'est des emplois qui ont un sens car
c'est dans l'industrie qu'on invente et
solutions de la transition écologique et
énergétique etc des emplois qui créent
de la richesse sur les territoires qui
répare le déchirement territoriale que
nous pouvons vivre aujourd'hui dans ces
structures high tech
tout est fait pour captiver les plus
jeunes et redonner de l'attrait à une
filière trop méconnu en fait on
connaissait les usines à un moment qui
telle usine avec les hauts fourneaux et
c'est aujourd'hui l'industrie 4.0 en
fait quand vous rentrez dans une usine
2.0 vous pouvez déjeuner par terre ce
n'est plus rien à voir et en fait les
jeunes se rendre compte à travers toutes
ces animations et à travers toutes ses
rencontres avec les professionnels que
l'industrie aujourd'hui c'est the place
to be où ils ont envie de travailler en
tout 3000 personnes dont de nombreux
lycéens ont répondu présents à la sortie
ils sont plutôt convaincu on nous
expliquer votre chose parce qu'il ya
plein de choses qu'on ignore sur
l'industrie mai
voilà qu on apprend beaucoup de choses
et il reste beaucoup de choses à
apprendre ça a permis de savoir dans
quelle voie j'allais partir des
prochaines voilà ça va être quoi du coup
je sais pas trop encore peut-être avoir
industrielle technologique et ça tombe
bien car la filière recrutent
le french fable lui s'apprête déjà à
repartir il s'installera au creusot en
bourgogne à partir de jeudi